Su esposa fue asaltada cuando iba a su trabajo de maestra de preescolar,
y estaban preocupados por la seguridad de su joven hija.
¿Qué podían hacer?
¿Huir?
¿Buscar asilo en otro país?
No querían hacer eso.
Sólo querían vivir en su país sanos y salvos,
pero sus opciones eran limitadas.
Así que ese mes,
Juan Carlos trasladó a su familia a un lugar más seguro
mientras se unía a un grupo de migrantes en el largo y peligroso viaje
desde Centroamérica
a un trabajo que un familiar dijo que estaba abierto para él en EE. UU.
A estas alturas todos sabemos lo que les esperaba
en la frontera entre EE. UU. y México.
los que cruzaban por allí recibían los castigos cada vez más severos
Los procesos penales por cruzar ilegalmente,
la detención inhumana
y, lo más terrible, la separación de las familias.
Estoy aquí para decirles que este tratamiento no sólo está mal,
sino que es innecesario.
Esta creencia de que la única manera de mantener el orden
es con medios inhumanos
es inexacta;
y de hecho, lo contrario es lo cierto.
Sólo un sistema humano creará orden en la frontera.
Cuando se dispone de un viaje seguro, ordenado y legal a los EE. UU,
muy pocas personas eligen un viaje inseguro,
desordenado o ilegal.
Bien, entiendo que la idea
de que la inmigración legal podría resolver la crisis fronteriza
podría sonar un poco fantasiosa.
Pero aquí está la buena noticia:
Lo hemos hecho antes.
He estado trabajando con la inmigración por años
en el Instituto Cato
y en otros centros de investigación en Washington, D.C
y como asesor político de un miembro republicano del Congreso,
negociando una reforma migratoria bipartidista;
y he visto de primera mano
cómo EE. UU. ha implementado un sistema de orden humano en la frontera
para México.
Se llama programa de trabajadores invitados.
Y aquí están las mejores noticias.
Podemos replicar este éxito para Centroamérica.
Por supuesto, algunas personas
todavía necesitarán pedir asilo en la frontera.
Pero para entender lo exitoso
que podría ser esto para inmigrantes como Juan Carlos,
entender que, hasta hace poco,
casi todos los inmigrantes arrestados por la Patrulla Fronteriza eran mexicanos.
En 1986,
cada agente de la Patrulla Fronteriza arrestó a 510 mexicanos,
más de uno por día.
Para el 2019, este número era sólo ocho.
Eso es uno cada 43 días.
Es una reducción del 98 %.
Y, ¿a dóndehan ido todos los mexicanos?
El cambio más significativo
es que EE. UU. comenzó a emitir
cientos de miles de visas de trabajador invitado a los mexicanos,
para que puedan venir legalmente.
José Vásquez Cabrera fue uno de los primeros trabajadores invitados
en aprovechar esta expansión de visa
Le dijo al "New York Times" que antes de su visa
había hecho aterradores cruces ilegales de la frontera,
desafiando casi el calor mortal y la traición del paisaje.
Una vez, una serpiente mató a un miembro de su grupo.
Miles de otros mexicanos tampoco lo lograron,
muriendo deshidratados en los desiertos o ahogándose en el Río Grande.
Millones más fueron perseguidos y arrestados.
Las visas de trabajadores invitados casi han terminado con este caos inhumano.
Como dijo Vásquez Cabrera:
"Ya no tengo que arriesgar mi vida
para mantener a mi familia.
Y cuando estoy aquí, no tengo que vivir en la clandestinidad".
Este tipo de visas en verdad redujeron el número de cruces ilegales
más que el número de visas emitidas.
José Bacilio, otro trabajador invitado de mexicano, explicó por qué
al "Washington Post" en abril.
Dijo que, a pesar de que, este año, no había recibido una visa.
no arriesgaría sus posibilidades futuras
por cruzar ilegalmente.
Esto probablemente ayude a explicar por qué
desde 1996 hasta 2019
por cada trabajador mexicano admitido legalmente.
hubo una disminución en dos arrestos de mexicanos que cruzaban ilegalmente.
Ahora, es cierto,
los trabajadores invitados mexicanos hacen trabajos realmente difíciles:
recoger fruta, limpiar cangrejos,
hacer jardinería a 38 º C.
Y algunos críticos sostienen que las visas de estos trabajadores
no son realmente humanas
y que los trabajadores simplemente son esclavos maltratados,
pero Vásquez Cabrera pensó que una visa de trabajador invitado era una liberación,
no es una esclavitud;
y él, como casi todos los otros invitados,
escogió el camino legal sobre el ilegal, repetidamente.
La expansión de las visas de trabajadores invitados a los mexicanos
ha sido uno de los cambios humanos más significativos
en la política de inmigración de EE.UU.
Y ese cambio humano
impuso el orden en el caos.
Y, ¿dónde deja esto a los centroamericanos,
como Juan Carlos?
Bueno, los centroamericanos recibieron
sólo el 3 % de estas visas emitidas en el 2019,
aún cuando su porcentaje de arrestos en la frontera ha aumentado al 74 %.
EE. UU emitió sólo una visa de trabajador a un centroamericano
por cada 78 que cruzaron la frontera ilegalmente en el 2019.
Así que, si no pueden conseguir sus papeles en casa,
muchos se arriesgan,
viniendo a través de México para pedir asilo en la frontera
o cruzar ilegalmente,
incluso si, como Juan Carlos, prefieren venir a trabajar.
Los EE. UU. puede hacerlo mejor.
Necesita crear nuevas visas de trabajador invitado
específicamente para los centroamericanos.
Esto crearía un incentivo para que las empresas de EE.UU.
busquen y contraten a centroamericanos,
pagando sus vuelos a EE.UU.
y desviándolos de la ilegal y peligrosa caminata hacia el norte.
Los centroamericanos podrían construir vidas florecientes en casa,
sin necesidad de buscar asilo en la frontera
o cruzar ilegalmente,
liberando así un sistema abrumado.
Algunos dirán
que dejar que los trabajadores vayan y vengan
nunca funcionará en Centroamérica
donde la violencia es tan alta.
Pero de nuevo, funcionó en México,
aun cuando la tasa de asesinatos en México se triplicó en la última década,
a un nivel más alto que en gran parte de Centroamérica.
Y funcionaría para Juan Carlos,
quien dijo, a pesar de las amenazas,
que sólo quiere vivir en EE.UU. temporalmente,
para ganar suficiente dinero
para sostener a su familia en su nuevo hogar.
Incluso sugirió que un programa de trabajadores invitados
sería una de las mejores cosas para ayudar a hondureños como él.
Cintia, de Honduras, una madre soltera de 29 años con tres hijos,
parece estar de acuerdo.
Ella le dijo al "Wall Street Journal" que vino por un trabajo
para mantener a sus hijos y a su madre.
Encuestas realizadas a centroamericanos que viajan a través de México,
llevadas a cabo por el Colegio de la Frontera Norte en México,
confirman que Juan y Cintia son la norma.
La mayoría, no todos, pero la mayoría vienen por trabajo,
aunque, como los Riveras,
también pueden enfrentar, en casa, algunas amenazas reales.
¿Cuánto ayudaría un trabajo de bajo salario
a un hondureño, como Juan o Cintia?
Los hondureños como ellos ganan tanto
en un mes en los Estados Unidos
como en un año entero trabajando en Honduras.
Unos pocos años de trabajo en EE.UU.
pueden impulsar a un centroamericano hacia la clase media alta
donde la seguridad es más fácil de conseguir.
Lo que les falta a los centroamericanos no es el deseo de trabajar,
tampoco el deseo de contribuir a la economía estadounidense,
de contribuir a la vida de los estadounidenses.
Lo que les falta a los centroamericanos es una alternativa legal al asilo;
poder hacerlo legalmente.
Claro, un nuevo programa de trabajadores invitados
no resolverá el 100 % de este complejo fenómeno.
Muchos solicitantes de asilo todavía tendrán que buscar seguridad
en la frontera de EE.UU.
Pero con la reducción de los flujos,
podemos encontrar más fácilmente maneras de tratarlos humanamente.
Pero en última instancia,
ninguna política ha demostrado hacer más
para crear un sistema de inmigración que sea a la vez humano
y ordenado
que deje que los trabajadores vengan legalmente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)